trong tương tương lâu thì về dưới sẽ có tìm,
thì cũng sống được thói cho cụng đến nổi giữa phải lo lắng gì đâu.
Lời sao đó tới được bả trở về cái chân bôi dưới.
Tăng cái xa đoàn ngừng cố ý cho kết tới về mấy tụi để chơi mấy thẳng trở.
Thì đến kết, bả chân đến nổi đôi, bả ngục cái xe,
của đặt con sạp pháp, pháp có một thân niên đặt con sạp pháp ngôi,
bả vẻ để khỏi li, đánh cái xưa, hơi dòi.
Hãy có nhiều người ta ở đây nó, nó của chúng mình chúng ta đã chất vì khi lúc.
Và phần ai của xè mong như nó đã tại tin như thế nào.
Tụi nên tơi nổi nổi, bả mấy mì sáng nơi,
của ý vẻ không bao giờ có thể tăng đúng.
Tìm mình và đúng đường, lực đường rất tài dạ,
cái cà thành phần, trong lưu, trong lưu và tìt được,
trong xe gó, cái phải nói, những chính tối của mẹ phải đoàn,
kinh phụ cách măng lần tơi, mấy mắm việc nắm ở phá rây.
Vô làm nhiên vô đối ngoài và vô làm trực mi, vô là,
được lương, được lương chính kí, được lương, vô là quân trúng đồ.
Thế thì, cái phối hợp trong vô ngoài, cái phải nói rất là nhiều dưới.